Okay,
good morning folks.
We should be live here. I set the stream
title with the category.
All right. So, um,
I'm here early today.
I was out way too late last night at a
dinner, so I'm pretty tired.
Um, I figured I may as well just start
the stream early.
There will be some interruptions, but I
do want to finish the algorithm today.
Let me remember what the hell I was
doing.
there's a quite a bit of stuff in this
change.
Um, I was trying to make it so that you
can recalculate the advantage
if you sample the segment from the start
and you get a higher reward.
I believe that's what I was doing.
Hello. We are uh 90%
of the way there with no domain
knowledge. That's the current progress.
There's one tricky last thing. This
actually might be it right here.
I suspect we will have to fiddle with a
few more things,
but we should be quite close. One second
here.
Yeah. So, we will see how this works.
Um, I also know what diagnostics we're
going to need for the last phase of dev
once we get it to stable full solves.
Yeah. So here's the exact thing that
this is 50% of the CL samples
come directly from the start saved
segment head.
If the rollout terminals from the head
is equal or better than the stored one
priorities are refreshed.
This replaces decay and other dumb
heristics,
Hey, light.
Uh, I'm working on
the last chunk of the algorithm
which has to do with using advantage
only
to put stuff into the buffer and then
figuring out anywhere that's screwing
up.
Yeah, Jess, I was out super late last
night. Um, I didn't get much sleep, so
and I did a 15K yesterday, so there's no
way run is happening today.
Uh, so I figured I would just stream
early. I'm there going to be some
interruptions. cuz I don't usually start
this early cuz there's some stuff I have
to do. Plus, I have to get breakfast at
some point. But I figured we would at
least get a little bit of work done in
the morning and then see from there.
Um, actually, I'm going to wait until we
get towards the end here. I'm going to
wait until we get a little towards the
end, maybe.
Are you meing or do you not need or do
you not know how to multiply by 6?
It's like 9 and a half miles entirely
over hills
in the [ __ ] sun.
is admittedly not terrible terrible,
but
it's enough that I'd better get some
sleep afterwards if you want me to get
up and run the same hills And
yeah, so we're getting completely
merckked on the latch. touch here.
So, we need to get diagnostics first and
then we can Yeah, we're jumping ahead.
Yeah, I mean admittedly 15k is not that
bad either.
Um but hilly and in the sun is
pretty rough.
I mean, it wasn't terrible terrible by
any means, but
at least let me get like eight hours of
sleep
if I'm going to do another 10 this
morning.
Like, I basically would have had to get
like five or six hours of sleep to get
up early enough.
I got seven as is, which is like that's
the bare minimum for me to be able to do
anything.
Less than that is like may as well just
call the day a wash.
Let's see what we got here.
Use the constellation shader. Oh, no you
didn't.
That's pretty damn cool. What we got for
sweeps?
Wait, is this one log log or is this log
linear? This is log linear.
Okay, you have
this is better than log linear with
compute though, right?
50% make it to the end. But it looks
like you have better than log linear
with compute.
This is a weird number of experiments.
Is this like many different sweeps put
together?
Because you have a very high density of
points. Unless I guess this is not
filtered to paro points would be my
guess. This is probably without the paro
filter.
But it looks like this just needs to
spend a little bit more compute
potentially because it looks like you do
have good compute scaling here.
GP should already sample in the two bill
range.
All right.
Well, offer is open if you want a PR.
Um,
and I will give you a review of it on
the RL side.
That's a nice result, though. That's a
very cool result.
So yeah, let me know, man.
I've got uh the crazy ass algorithm I'm
working on right now.
Go warp.
Uh, it depends how you set it up in the
build. So, I wouldn't want to add it as
a
I would not want to add it as a like
install depth. But what you can do and
what we do for enemies that have that,
we put it conditionally. So, if you do
um build sh like Majoko or build sh
warp,
then it installs it. So, you just don't
put you don't put big heavy depths in
the default path.
you only provide them when people ask
for them.
And then um
it's also it's fine like if we ship the
next Docker version we if it's not
gigantic,
we can put stuff in the Docker as well.
So it's pre-built.
I'm interested what you're actually
using it for and the extent that it's
required. I wouldn't be surprised if you
could just do that in like a few hundred
lines of code without it or less.
Can I join server?
Yeah, it's just Discord. PG/puffer.
Ray tracing.
Wait, what do you need ray tracing for?
The physics calc is not ray trace,
right?
What does it use ray tracing on though?
I guess um
like contacts or something.
Stupid logs. Stupid logs.
Liar.
Uh,
that's one of the things where you
actually need a custom encoder, by the
way.
like you can't just flatten all the
points at a certain point like after a
certain scale and just stick them into
the network. It doesn't work. We have a
very simple um entity based encoder that
will work for points like that.
I haven't gotten it PR in yet though
There it is.
Point the LAR in the right.
Oh, if you have one beam. Yes. I thought
you meant um
I was thinking of like the [ __ ] tons of
beams or like the rotating ones, you
know, they have on uh on AVs.
Yeah. If it's just one beam, then you're
fine. You don't need fancy architecture.
They're problems for which LAR is used
where they essentially give you a point
cloud.
And uh that type of thing is more
annoying for a single LAR. You also
shouldn't need ray tracing for one lidar
though. Like you shouldn't need um a
fancy library for that. That's just
fast.
You should only need the library for
like a ton of
a ton of LAR.
All right, cool. Hopefully this gives us
some diagnostics.
The key detail why uh now is why our
advantage metric is not corresponding
perfectly to
Frontier States.
That's the key difficulty.
Where are latch timers?
Okay. L10
200 mil
free beer
which Matthew Sim implemented
I believe it's difficult. I don't
believe it's being done efficiently at
the moment though.
You know, I like I said, I haven't
really gone too deep into the um robotic
sim stuff because it's only maybe like
number three
on
list of interest for puffer
applications.
That's the first two.
Biological Sim in material science.
I just have the $100 a month sub at this
point and I I don't really run out.
I got sick of giving anthropic money.
Check signal. Hang on. Let me get my
stupid phone.
Apparently, I don't even have it on this
phone. Let me check.
Okay, there's some variance on this as
well, so it's not as bad as expected.
Hang on. You might have to send me the
thing again.
I hate these stupid apps, man.
right. If you send me whatever the hell
it is again, it'll work.
$100 plan burning fast. It doesn't
though.
Kinvert, you're vibe coding your entire
everything like no [ __ ]
took a lot of rework.
All right, I will take a look at that
end. That sounds fun.
Particularly if you took the time to
rework it
as promised a PhD level personal
assistant. Well, they [ __ ] lied.
Or yeah, you technically got a PhD level
assistant. You got one of the [ __ ]
idiot ones.
Okay, man. We can definitely chat about
that.
right, I sent you something. We can uh
we can chat on that more as well later
if you want to set up a call or
whatever. I also got to ask Spencer a
couple things on that.
well, it's not. We can sign exclusivity
things convert but they would be
narrowly scoped and also with reasonable
time requirements around them and at a
very large premium to our current work.
We have not signed any thus far.
Like if somebody wants to pay us 10
times the amount in an area where like
we're not super interested in expanding
that much anyways for um you know a year
or two exclusivity.
Uh that's something we would consider
Non yeah there's non-compete is a thing
that you do with existing companies. Um,
when you are the contractor, it's more
exclusivity.
They're being skipped by admission
because high sol has okay
L2 over a full segment still rewards
dense residual value error.
Dilute a very localized frontier spike
if the rest of the segment has near
zero error.
You don't want to smear it across the
entire thing.
This is it. This thing is just stupid as
[ __ ] I swear it's like the inverse of
what we'd want. Huber makes no sense
here.
I don't like this metric. I don't think
it's robust enough, but it's like a
decent start. We'll see if this doesn't
fix it. Then there's something else
screwy.
Oops.
I'll put that on stream.
Don't need that.
We're good.
All right. So, um what we wanted to do
with this here,
what information is left to analyze?
Um, the big annoyance at the moment,
frontier segments. So, segments that
should be in unknown territory getting
surprising reward.
They're not getting admitted to the
buffer consistently enough.
That's our main issue.
What would you recommend for somebody
who wants to study ML?
Uh, hang on.
My guide for new people in ML is well,
it's more general stuff.
these two articles this one's RL but
this is my general programming in ML
article this is my single highest rated
piece of content
I would suggest this quite heavily
reinforcement learning continuous time
and space do marketing and buffer that's
um PhDing at Boston.
Yeah, I mean um it's a good library to
use for academic research for sure if
you're compute constraint.
Marketing is more so for companies.
Okay, we had 180 mil steps on L9.
Hopefully that gets us some useful data.
So, this definitely doesn't just work,
it seems.
Well,
I guess up to 200 mil is believable.
Oh, so they just sent you a giant pile
of math.
enjoy your big pile of math, I suppose.
I don't know what you want me to do with
that.
It's like, oh, yes, there is a small
error on proof in
on
Formula 18, right? Right here. There's a
small No. Like I have no [ __ ] idea
what I'm looking at, dude.
Other than I'm looking at a problem
where there's like a very simple
discretization of it for most cases that
works without giant pile of math.
train an agent to do one v one bow
fights. Did you port the end?
Wait, let's see.
It's in general.
Did I scroll up?
Oh,
wait. Did you train this on
built a sim? Okay,
that's very cool, actually.
Okay, that's cool.
Damn.
What's the um
Okay, so it must be fast because I see
billions here
and ELO. Okay, selfplay. This is good.
Okay, this is you trying to shoot the
thing, I see.
That's cool, man.
Are we going to get a PR for this?
Yeah, I think I remember that vaguely.
Things are going well. We're doing some
algorithm dev, man. So many cool M's. I
also saw Didn't Wasn't there like
is this super old? Yeah, this is We
never got a PR from this guy. He had
like a bunch of M's and he never really
PR stuff, right?
We definitely need some new ends in uh
in Puffer. So,
Minecraft engine for even like a couple
PvP things would be very cool.
I don't think they're going to take
kindly to your doing RL wrong. I think
it's more so like, hey, are you
interested in, you know, testing any of
your stuff experimentally? We've got a
really good RL. Like, yeah, you're
talking to a very different audience
there, Anes. Like, that paper doesn't
even have experiments.
Office gym in background. Oh, no. I'm
still there most of the time.
Replica of Minecraft source, which is
not open source.
It's a replica of Minecraft source code
which is not open source.
Wait, but that's not how that works.
You're allowed to like
that that's clean room engineering. You
don't have the source code and you wrote
your own version. The only thing that we
would have to do is if we really wanted
to be safe, we'd swap the assets,
right?
So yeah, if anything, we would just use
like a nonofficial Minecraft texture
pack and we'd be fine.
Man, so many cool ends being submitted.
I need to actually just go through and
review all of them. Just got to finish
up the latest algorithm portion. I can
do that.
hit diamond last November and finally
focusing
more on genetic aletic
algs.
H
cool a whole of a game.
That's funny.
We bullish on AI now. We've always been
bullish on the type of AI we're doing.
I'm um
the models are just whatever. I can kind
of do stuff with or without them.
I do things a little differently.
through the papers and try to understand
[ __ ]
Yeah, my guess is you're talking to
somebody who's um pretty out of touch to
send you that heavy of a math paper in
domestic home robots. That's actually
basically at the bottom of my list of
things, man. Like that's kind of those
one of the like that's one of those like
really stupid think about the future,
what do we want things
that basically doesn't do jack like that
does jack [ __ ] for everyone.
There are much much more important
things to be doing with puffer
Sunday Robotics. Bill, I don't know who
that is.
startup. I have not heard of them.
Oh, unless Is that the one? Is that the
one with like the cute little robot that
sits on your desk?
All right, thanks for dropping by.
Okay, so
I think with this we'll have tried
enough different variations of loss that
uh if this doesn't work then there's
something wrong with the signals coming
in
and it looks like it is.
I guess we'll let it run. We'll let this
play out.
That's Mondo.
That one was cool.
This is going to be several stages, I
think.
There's also the question of whether or
not we can expand.
We do really want to be able to expand
from the existing states we're searching
as well, don't we?
That's tougher.
mining and dangerous work.
Well,
other robots that do dangerous work,
yes, that's useful.
Like, you shouldn't have humanoids
mining. That's [ __ ] stupid.
Yes, Anes. because it's clearly a theory
paper.
This is like asking me like, "Hey, why
doesn't Puffer have a whole bunch of
math and proofs for everything?" It's
like, well,
this is not a uh a theoryheavy project.
This is experimental.
that would be my attitude because I'm
because I'm not a theorist.
Okay, we still have the absolutely
horrible 600 step latch.
It actually lost the 10 signal for a
second there, which is very bad.
Okay, so this definitely not solved.
Why the hell are we getting screwy
advantages then?
That's the real question.
The video I made is inside the real
Minecraft game ported
unsourcable code.
Well, you can't have copied the thing
isn't running in Java, right?
movement
like I can take a look at it. My guess
is you'll be fine if um
if we just do like a a simple ray client
with different graphics. It should be
fine.
I mean, I'll take a look. I suspect it
will be fine if we just like mess with
the graphics
up top use cases of AI right now where
that I would like there to be.
because now it's like games, robotics,
and defense.
But um longer term, my top three are
uh biological sim, material science, and
then nonhumanoid robotics like
industrial arms, and uh specialized
specialized machinery.
Well, it is sim to sim, but the thing is
Minecraft is simple enough that you
don't really have the uh the domain gap.
I think if you PR it without the assets,
I can look at it. But um what I would do
is I would just throw together a very
simple
like a really simple ray client for it.
You could even start with flat textures
though. I think we can probably at least
put like some sort of reasonable texture
pack on it.
Well, we at least know the failure mode
now. That makes sense.
What's the failure mode? Um, so for
whatever reason, it seems like we're
getting advantage spikes, like high
advantage spikes on solved levels,
which is an important thing to
understand.
Of course, it just adds like piles and
piles and piles of metrics.
Try that and tell you when a PR is
ready. Thank you.
Thank you. That'll I mean that'll be a
very nice end to have.
if you want to go like very nuts. Um
I bet if you gave the agent uh if you
like added a little bit of terrain or
and gave the agent some elytra, you'd
get some ludicrously complex stuff out
of it.
favorite people working in RL
don't have papers that don't require you
to be ramen to understand
um honestly they're not that many left
like there's still some good work coming
out of flare like Oxford flare
Michael and company um Jacob Forers's
lab
uh Eugene's group is doing stuff on the
drive
that we work on.
Couple other things.
Um Ryan's at Jeff Cloon's lab still.
He's doing some cool work.
Most papers don't look like the one that
you sent me.
I don't know even know if there are
people bow fighting. Yeah. So, that's
the type of thing that Puffer will kind
of just wreck.
The thing is just like godly here. Let
me show you something real quick. I only
have like one quick snippet of this, but
I don't know if you know Runescape at
all. Um,
let me show you this clip. I have a clip
of it doing something that's like top
maybe quarter% of players.
behind shield. Blowpipe tagging tags
with twisted bow. Third minion tags.
Changes prayers. Gets behind shield just
in time for this hit. Dodges projectiles
on the ground. Switches weapons.
Blowpipes this. Switches prayers. Still
dodging projectiles.
All minions tagged. No longer damaging
minions. Dodging projectiles. Staying
behind shield. switching prayers and
still hitting in between ticks with
twisted bow.
This is like top quarter percentile
gameplay. Like top quarter of a percent
level player gameplay.
So that was one cool thing.
Um anything that's like mechanical like
that puffer will kind of just shred
instantly.
We're going to run this little analysis
thing and then I'm going to like one or
two more experiments and then I'm going
to call it to get my breakfast
and I'll be back for another stream
around noon
complex mechanics. Yeah, that's um
Runescape is no longer just like click
thing, wait till die, right? There's
pretty fancy endgame content that's very
mechanical these days.
like there's just a huge number of
things to pay attention to and react to
and like you know act accordingly.
Um the PvP in Runescape is also
ludicrously fast. It's very very high
APM.
I'm trying to think. Let's figure out in
the meantime like if we have any ideas
for why um
do we have any ideas for why we could be
getting these spikes.
Like I could see this happening because
maybe the old levels are not fully
solved yet and then we're getting the
new segment in very early.
I don't think that would fully explain
it though.
There could be some leaking
normalization or something on the
advantages. Maybe we're checking like
normed advantages.
That could do it.
so I this is the key thing though that
we need to figure out. We need to figure
out why
why advantage is not being a consistent
metric
um for what we want to do with it
I think probably all the problems are
just coming from this. And if we figure
this out, it should just work perfectly
because we know that it essentially if
you get the right data into the buffer,
it does work perfectly. We know that you
see the right data during training.
So the question is just why is it not
getting into the buffer?
Probably should try some
transformer-based crap at some point.
It's so obnoxious for RL though.
It's just so obnoxious.
And don't tell me it's going to randomly
work better just with diagnostics being
added.
It is kind of noisy, but I I it'll get
stuck somewhere, I'd imagine.
Right.
We essentially need to know
when we attempt to in when we attempt to
add a next level solve segment to the
buffer and it gets rejected.
Um what are the other segments with
higher priority and what levels do they
correspond to and what is the solve rate
of those levels?
I am trying to think.
other than like maybe this is just
happening because levels aren't fully
solved yet. I don't know.
It could be just accumulation of many
small errors.
We also need to sort of like we need to
plot the advantage over time or
something.
We can probably come up with a bunch of
visuals
right, there we go. We're stuck on level
12.
Then we solve,
but with a ludicrously long latch time.
500 mil steps.
Oh, I could also be misunderstanding
part of the advantage calc.
Oh, I think I am actually
misunderstanding part of the advantage
calc, aren't I?
I am under I I misunderstanding a core
thing here.
Okay.
Well, now I have a lot more to think
about.
Okay. Well, that's actually a different
interpretation. Cool.
Well, that's at least something that's
more like reasonable and straightforward
to solve. Um, I'm going to take a break
here, folks, cuz it is almost 10:00 and
I got to go get myself breakfast and I
got to call at 11:00. Um, I will be back
streaming probably around 12 Pacific, so
in a little over two hours and I'll be
live for the rest of the day. So, if
you're interested in my stuff and you'd
like to check out the research, if
you're interested in Puffer generally,
um, take a look at puffer.ai. If you're
new around here, start the repo. Feed
the puff for a star helps us out a lot.